it's the most wonderful time of the year
and by that I mean it's the return of
Oprah's Favorite Things
isn't that like no I love this a field
of truth less salt in it with less salt
Oh protested and Oprah approved it's her
favorite things just in time for the
holiday I just am done with gifts I
think the most special gift is something
that is something that's gonna
absolutely come from a space that people
know your heart was in it this is a yes
okay yes say yes to truffles s 101
tasteful gift ideas handpicked by Oprah
with help from her friends like Gayle
King the list includes everything from
stocking stuffers to luxury items so the
range is from 16 dollars up to $1,500
which gets you a knockout brand-new TV
state-of-the-art TV and then there's
everything in between English muffins
and make sure I get this spread and that
Fred to take that okay thank you really
likes you if this Christmas you get
these English muffins from Oprah on the
list
that means she really thinks you're a
really good friend she went crazy for
these in the run-through
the first time she tasted them by the
time she had left the shoot she had
ordered nine orders I wasn't kidding
when I said Oprah likes bread you've
heard about the English muffins
how about big-bottomed biscuits there's
jumbo sized red lipstick that'll set you
back about 85 bucks and jimmies Oprah
pairs with Michael Kors high tops she
was rocking out in the red shoes it
helps to when you're listening to
Beyonce while you're doing the photo
shoot always work I love the adult
coloring books you know Oprah is one of
those little kids that was great at
coloring wouldn't you expect that she
colored within the lines and she still
does color within the lines she like
this right away or for that one of these
too
and for the person on your list who
really wants to live like the media
mogul and who doesn't there's always the
Oprah cookbook I was at her house
recently in California and we were both
sitting there what to eat said why don't
we pick something out of the book and we
did we picked the corn and tomato salad
along with some great tasting fish all
her favorites are in this month's Oh
magazine but what's the
just give Oprah's ever been given I
received a painting as a gift where I
was both cross-eyed and my nose was on
the wrong side of my face I thought that
was the strangest one I got
there's plenty more from Oprah and Gayle
Thursday on ET and for a closer look at
Oprah's Favorite Things head over to ETL
my calm